buenos dias raúl pues en el italiano y
el español yo diría que es un jugador
que nos ha dejado a todos una huella muy
grande porque date cuenta que la
generación de mayor nacimiento aquí en
españa precisamente coincidió con la
edad de adolescencia de esos chavales
que queríamos ser todos maradona a
partir de ahí pues todo el fútbol
español cuando vino al barcelona y luego
cuando se fue a italia siguió
continuamente el desarrollo del fútbol
de este astro que aquí nos deleitaba
cada fin de semana cada partido incluso
fijate que hubo un enfado cuando el
presidente del barcelona de afecte ha
fallecido josé luís núñez decidió que se
fuera a italia porque todos nos quedamos
frustrados por no seguir viendo a diego
armando maradona y en italia y el jugaba
al nápoles y la fiesta fue total el
apoyo y el recuerdo de este jugador está
pegado a la piel de cada uno de los de
paul y tanos porque allí con un equipo
menor entre comillas consiguió hacerles
campeones así es josé y también le
preguntó cómo será recordado en europa y
en el resto del mundo maradona
pues mira estos días zinedine zidane el
técnico del real madrid dijo que era una
pérdida para el mundo diego pablo
simeone también argentino rescató de
diego sobre todo el aprendizaje de la
humildad y del fútbol que él tenía y
cómo se convirtió en alguien a quien
seguir aquí es recordado por todos en
estos días compañeros que fueron en el
barcelona que estuvieron en el sevilla y
también aficionados todos están y te
puedo confesar que todos los medios de
comunicación todas las portadas de los
diarios de prensa no solamente
deportivos y todo el seguimiento en
radios ha sido continuo porque maradona
va a quedar siempre en la memoria de
todos porque para aquí para muchos aquí
es considerado el mejor jugador del
mundo en este asunto de tocar la pelota
con la clase con la que hacía maradona
siempre ese destello en su fútbol que
era totalmente distinto así es josé y
también pues le tengo que preguntar cómo
queda en la figura de maradona sobre
todos los excesos donde precisamente en
europa empezó ya a coquetear con todas
las drogas que él sabemos era adicto o
maradona
sí ese es un asunto que aquí se ha
tocado un poquito menos estos días
porque realmente lo que se ha vivido
aquí ha sido una especie de recuerdo de
adolescencia generalizado o de infancia
para muchos seguidores y para muchos
periodistas todos hablaban de en qué
momento entrevisté a maradona en qué
momento vi a maradona en un campo de
juego en qué momento observé sus vídeos
el asunto de todo lo que fue su vida
personal aquí se ha tratado menos
digamos que en este instante como una
especie de entre comillas respeto a la
figura deportiva de maradona pero sí sí
que es algo que se va analizar es algo
que se comenta y que lógicamente se
tiene como ejemplo a la inversa saber
que ese camino que maradona llevó que
con la humildad con el modo de ser de
diego armando maradona
aquí las compañías no le fueron bien en
absoluto y que es un camino que para
cualquier otro deportista hay que llevar
a la inversa hay que saber cómo dirigir
la vida de un futbolista que se
encuentra desde la mayor humildad desde
la mayor proeza con todo lo que es un
contrato millonario con muchos amigos
gratis y con muchas personas que no le
llevaron por un camino adecuado
jose pero es preferible siempre
quedarnos con oberá muchísimas gracias
por estar aquí con nosotros en francés
que tenga usted un feliz resto de día ya
en españa